this past III Capcom revealed to the
world Resident Evil seven and for the
first time in franchise history the game
will take place entirely in first-person
Resident Evil 7 looks to bring the
franchise back to its roots but the
game's shift the first person has caused
so many people to say that it doesn't
feel like a Resident Evil game well I
think we need to all ask ourselves the
question what is a Resident Evil game
sure we can say the series is all about
horror but with the main games and
countless spin-offs having deviated so
far from that path it's sometimes hard
to say throughout the years Resident
Evil has changed a whole lot with the
franchise shifting from survival horror
to action hordes at a Mario Party and
now it's a first-person horror but how
did all this happen how do we even get
to this point well to answer that
question we're gonna have to go way back
to the 90s back in the early 90s the
survival horror genre was kind of going
through an identity crisis most games
that were categorized as such felt more
like point-and-click adventures than
what we know today to be survival horror
there were titles like the CEMP guests
that loosely in by the horror genre but
mostly in the sense that their stories
were about ghosts and ghouls
one of the bigger games to come out of
this era was alone in the dark a game
that while can't be in somewhat
goofy-looking it still laid the
groundwork for horror games to come and
while it was a critical and commercial
success eventually spawning four sequels
it wasn't quite the horror game that
most people were looking for that's when
a game designer Shinji Mikami was
entrusted with developing a new game for
Capcom one that would be loosely based
off their own NES game sweet home now
sweet home was more of a horror RPG but
it was the game setting and specific
mechanics that influenced this new games
design it was quite a bit of a departure
from Mikami's past projects whose resume
consisted primarily of Disney licensed
games but he was up to the task and got
to work on what we now know today as
Resident Evil
when Resident Evil was released it
changed everything the pre-rendered
environments aided in giving the game a
truly creepy feel and the inventory
system limited the items you could pick
up forcing the players to be selective
with what they held but it was the
control scheme that pushed the game into
new territory players would rotate their
character with left and right and move
them forward by pressing up regardless
of where they were on the screen what
this did was slow the characters
movements down as it was impossible to
just bolt out of a room at the first
sign of trouble
players would find themselves struggling
to maneuver their character during these
tense moments making zombie
confrontations all the more stressful
the game also had this sense of dread
that made you feel vulnerable at every
turn the moments between each room
separated by the creepiest loading
screen you'll ever encounter were
incredibly tense as you were never quite
sure what kind of monsters were waiting
behind the door there could be zombies
like nizam be dogs bees crows snakes or
even these guys and while okay the
dialogue might be more famous than the
actual game itself that was too close
you were almost a jiggle sandwich you're
right that was all part of the games
charm the b-movie horror aspect felt
very reminiscent of a George a Romero's
script and the camp eNOS of the game
would eventually become a defining
characteristic of the franchise
Capcom had set a precedent with resident
evil so they quickly got to work on the
follow-up this new game featured a pair
of new protagonists more numerous and
grotesque zombies as well as a more
modern setting it was shaping up to be a
bigger faster and more intense Resident
Evil than ever before but a lil over a
year into its development the game ran
into a roadblock despite being almost
finished disagreements between the
director and the producer of the game
cause Capcom to completely scrapped the
project and rebuild it from the ground
up this unfinished game dubbed Resident
Evil 1.5 in retrospect was never
actually released to the public but what
Rose of its ashes was something
spectacular
in 98 Resident Evil 2 was released
building upon everything that fans love
from the first game with better graphics
music environments the game gave players
a much more cinematic experience which
aid in making the game even scarier than
the first in addition to the technical
advancements the plot went much deeper
into the mythos of Resident Evil going
beyond the single mansion setting the
game now to place in Raccoon City itself
with your character given a much bigger
environment to explore and get lost in
this is one the game started investing
more time into its backstory as you
slowly learned about the virus where it
came from and ultimately how it affected
and infected the residents of the city
Resident Evil 2 also introduced what
they called the zapping system which
gave the player different storylines and
puzzles for each character regardless of
the trouble development Resident Evil 2
was a success it went on to become the
best-selling single platform game for
the franchise with almost 5 million
copies of the PlayStation version being
sold with the incredible success of
Resident Evil 2 Capcom was on upward
trajectory becoming the flagship
developer for the survival horror genre
countless other horror game franchises
were launched in the wake of Resident
Evil's first two games including Silent
Hill parasite even hey even Capcom Zone
Dino Crisis
but the company knew they couldn't
stagnate and kept the momentum going by
releasing resin evil 3 nemesis in 1989
which was only a year after Resident
Evil 2 the game had a much shorter
development cycle dance predecessors as
Capcom was attempting to work on
multiple Resident Evil projects at the
time but with the arrival of the ps2
just a mere year and a half away they
all knew that time was running out a
small team that had been working on the
spin-off game suddenly found themselves
tasked with making Capcom's third main
line Resident Evil title
but the game stayed fairly true to the
resonable name given the players control
of Jill Valentine and were tasked with
once again exploring Raccoon City the
biggest change however was the addition
of nemesis the daunting unstoppable
zombie with a rocket launcher that
stalks you the entire game
nemesis brought in a slightly different
terror one that was a lot more
action-oriented during the encounters
you could choose to hold your ground and
fight or just simply run away it made
the game more frantic and with the
inclusion of a 180 turn and dodge move
it ever so slightly into that a new
direction that the series would go in
but we're not quite there yet
a year after nemesis Resident Evil Code
Veronica was released and while it
didn't possess a number at the end of
the title it was by all means still part
of the main line Resident Evil story
heck the developers even consider it to
be the true sequel tour as able to code
veronica was the first Resident Evil
game to be released on the system not
named PlayStation with the power of the
Dreamcast allowing the game to have
actual real-time environments no more
pre-rendered stuff even though the game
is widely considered to be good the one
thing that it didn't do was move the
series in any new direction yeah you had
the new features that were introduced in
Resident Evil 3 but the game felt nearly
identical to it in terms of mechanics
which really isn't surprising
considering that they were in
development at the same time it may not
have been the groundbreaking sequel that
people were expecting it to be but code
Veronica did have a few things to call
its own namely it featured some of the
most ridiculous cutscenes to date and
was a precursor to how ludicrous the
series would get news future Games
after the success of code veronica res
evil creator shinji mikami began the
arduous task of remaking the original
game he was convinced that the first
Resident Evil had not aged well he felt
a remake would allow new fans to really
appreciate it more so production began
in early 2001 and over the course of the
next year magic happened
the game transformed into a thing of
beauty when that pushed the game view to
its limits with real-time lighting
motion captured character movements and
even particle effects the graphical
redesign was what made the game it gave
players a terrifying atmosphere that the
original game promised with no
compromises it had only been six years
in one console generation since the
original Resident Evil yet the leap in
graphical quality was astronomical but
despite all the improvements made to the
game and how much effort was put into
making them one of the best Resident
Evil experiences to date there was one
thing that Capcom just couldn't control
the poor sales the remake was a GameCube
exclusive and while it sold 1.4 million
copies worldwide it was well below
Capcom's expectations and the following
game Resident Evil 0 solved just as
poorly despite it being made in the very
same vein as remake zero was criticized
for not doing enough to advance the
franchise critics were turned off by the
clunky controls and outdated mechanics
as I said and this was kind of a wake-up
call to Capcom they knew that people
want something different they knew that
need to be more than just scary they
needed to make the game fun if they want
their next game to be a success they'd
really have to shake things up a bit
I received special training via a secret
organization working under the direct
control of the president I was to assume
the responsibility of protecting the new
president's family
when resin evil for hit shelves in early
2005 people quickly found out that this
was not the same slow-moving zombie fest
like the previous incarnations in the
very first scene the game showed right
away just how different it was than any
other Resident Evil game before it you
controlled Leon Kennedy but the infamous
tank controls were gone the game instead
feature an over-the-shoulder camera that
allowed from greater movement and more
precise aiming the slow shambling
zombies were replaced by villagers that
sprinted full-speed at you wielding
sights axes and yep even chainsaws while
this new breed of enemy wasn't
classified as a zombie that didn't stop
them from being terrifying to deal with
their improved AI allowed them to chase
you up ladders break through windows and
doors and even Dodger attacks in short
they were a huge step up from the
previous game zombies and posed a
greater challenge than anyone had ever
seen in Resident Evil and with more
intelligent and dangerous enemies came
more powerful weapons
thanks to the new aiming system specific
areas like the head or legs could be
targeted giving players new ways to
disable their foes melee attacks were
also introduced and now could be
performed after stunning an enemy no
need to worry about being cornered or
chomped to death when you are single
roundhouse kick away from freeing
yourself Leon was more powerful in close
quarters and naturally it made the game
less scary yes these were some
astonishing changes that the game had
gone through but many felt that there
were changes for the better I mean the
first time Leon gets his head cut off by
the chainsaw guy was a defining moment
for most people and showed that this
game was not messing around
Resident Evil 4 garnered multiple Game
of the Year awards with critics praising
everything from its graphics to its
controls to even this voice acting for
once after the series that spent a good
decade scaring players with the survival
horror ways people seemed to embrace
this new look for the series this was
the change that they had been hoping for
so how do you follow up the alleged
masterpiece that was resonable for well
Capcom had the idea of keeping the game
very action-oriented and hopefully
capture that same lightning in a bottle
twice they were convinced that this is
what fans wanted the overwhelmingly
positive reaction towards Resident Evil
4 proved that people loved the changes
they introduced so how could reusing
that same formula of do any wrong with
Resident Evil 5 what we got was a game
that was heavy on action but light on
scares the game took place in Africa in
the blistering Sun so gone are the dark
spooky hallways of yore and maybe the
most controversial addition to the game
aside from the whole being in Africa
thing was the two-player co-op as
longtime fans felt to kill the spirit of
the series is the game so scary when
your teammate is loaded up with golden
eggs just a few steps away people didn't
seem to think so I'll be honest my time
with the reson evil 5 might have been
the most enjoyable out of all the
Resident Evil games because of the coop
for the first time shooting zombies
became a shared experience whether or
not the game was scary people couldn't
deny that it was fun by taking all the
gameplay elements from Resident Evil 4
and ramping up the intensity Capcom made
the conscious decision to continue
modifying the franchise they turned the
game into something that didn't quite
feel like Resident Evil in the
traditional sense but it was something
that could be appreciated on its own
pursuing that change with the resin evil
5 might have been the smartest thing
that Capcom could have done with the
game because at that point there was no
way it could have lived up to the
expectations that for said Resident Evil
5 may not been the runaway critical
success that 4 was but it wound up not
only being the best-selling Resident
Evil game of all time but also a
best-selling Capcom game of all time
having a game design around two players
not only set it apart from resi before
it propelled it into a category all its
own and set the stage for what came next
and three years later Capcom continued
down the action rabbit hole with the
Resident Evil six long story short the
game wound up being a disappointment for
res evil fans as it seemed to try to be
too many things at once
Capcom hit the accelerator on almost
every facet of the game incorporating an
expanded online co-op inter woven
storylines with every character and the
ability to shoot while running the last
point was something that resonance had
been requesting for well over a decade
and now that the feature was finally in
the game how did they react well to play
the bluntly people were torn the game
wasn't a complete train wreck in fact
some moments from the campaigns are as
thrilling as anything else the series
has done why it was trying to be so many
things at once it kind of lost sight of
what was good about the series if one
thing was clear it was that the Resident
Evil that fans knew from the 90s was
finally gone the series was now a
shooter with the only remaining ties to
horror being the name on the box
Capcom even went as far as to classify
the game as dramatic or clearly trying
to convince people that the game was
still the Resident Evil they knew and
loved but the damage had been done
fans were heartbroken and most of them
believe that they would never see
Resident Evil be a true survival horror
ever again this it ends now
so that brings us to Resident Evil 7 a
game that Capcom claims is going back to
a tour routes and not only is it in
first person it's entirely playable in
VR as well both of these things are new
to the series so these clearly aren't
the routes that they're talking about
it's hard to say how the first-person
perspective will help or hurt it but
what is clear is that Capcom has been
taking hints from contemporary horror
games like out laughs or Slenderman but
hey I played the demo and you know what
I like this new direction that they're
going with it I like this new Resident
Evil the gradual evolution of the series
has shown that Capcom is not afraid to
move on and try new things and I think
it's a wonderful example of a game never
getting too comfortable with what it is
even the small spin-off games speak
volumes about Capcom's tendency to
experiment with the franchise people
might point to a game like Resident Evil
5 and say oh this doesn't look like a
Resident Evil game to me but I'm not
entirely convinced that a single game
can define the series the true
definition of Resident Evil is as fluid
as the brains leaking out of a zombie's
head so to answer the question what is a
Resident Evil game well it's survival
horror it's dramatic or its first person
horror its third person action it's
campy dialogue it's bolder punchy it's
change its evolution it's the evolution
to me it's all of these things Resident
Evil might never be the same game that
it was in 1996 but that's okay
because much like the game's own t-virus
it's constantly morphing and mutating so
instead of trying to figure out what a
real Resident Evil game is all you need
to do is look back on its history and
you'll see that a Resident Evil game is
everything the series has been and
everything the series will become